des salles de spectacles des espaces de
recherche ou encore des mairies les
lieux saint quentinois répondent
présents pour les journées européennes
du patrimoine
à plaisir la clé des champs et le
théâtre espace coluche feront découvrir
l'envers du décor j'aurais moyen de
montrer au public dépeindre la salle
d'allumer le plateau ce qu'on appelle en
plein feu pour qu'il se rende compte que
quand on a tous ces projecteurs dans la
figure on ne voit plus le public on ne
fait que le ressentir thème de la
citoyenneté oblige des ouvertures
exceptionnelles
les hôtels de ville de trappes et
guyancourt organise des visites guidées
à elancourt n'a commanderie des
templiers ouvre elle aussi ses portes
l'occasion de pénétrer dans la chapelle
a rarement ouverte au public
la construction a été commencée fin du
xiième siècle et c'est une chapelle donc
du xiiie siècle
ce qui est intéressant ici c'est de la
revoir après réouverture donc à l'arrêt
ouvert en 2012 après restauration et
vous pourrez découvrir la restauration
qui a été fait à savoir la peinture les
peintures murales voilà et les vitraux
qui ont été nettoyées à deux pas de
saint quentin en yvelines à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse la fondation
morta panne vous replonge dans l'atelier
et les oeuvres de la sculptrice
d'origine hongroise
elle a sculpté ici nous ses premières
oeuvres parfois de très grande dimension
je pense notamment aux sculptures dont
maurice béjart s'être emparé pour faire
pour créer deux ballets et puis là
effectivement travaillé pendant une
dizaine d'années ici à travailler le
bois à ce moment là à découvrir aussi le
domaine de madame elisabeth à versailles
le théâtre national de saint quentin en
yvelines
le centre national du cinéma et de
l'image animée à bois d'arcy et bien
d'autres lieux encore le patrimoine vous
tend les bras